welcome back to las vegas now it is time
to get cooking with nanny bubbe in her
kitchen today she's showing us
how to prepare a delicious batch [ __ ]
sticky
mango chutney chicken did i say that
right nanny bubbe that is a
mouthful oh my gosh i'm not even sure i
could have gotten all of that
out how are you great it's a crazy name
but it sounds delicious
well and it is really quite fun and it's
actually a 17th
century way of cooking chicken which
basically means dispatching the [ __ ]
which means the young rooster hopefully
not too young
and we're going to start out with these
poultry shears now i'm wearing gloves
for two reasons
because i don't like touching raw
poultry but also because these shears
slip out of your hand
if they get wet or the fat makes them
slippery
yes it can and plus it goes flying
across the kitchen so we're going to
just
cut right through the bone just like
this
oh my gosh this is an opportunity i
should have started it
it is maybe i should we got it before
we're doing surgery
i don't know
that she's doing is on the screen if you
want to take a picture or
write yes down and what we're doing is
we're cutting right out the back of this
chicken which i've never had more
trouble than i'm having right now so
that's okay
that's the beauty of live tv right i
love
live tv for this reason there we go if
you'd been here a minute ago the other
chicken flew out of the oven and part of
it fell on the floor so we had to pick
that up so i'm just telling secrets here
there we go okay this was much harder
than it's
ever been before but there's the back
i'm freezing it
just for um uh soup and now what we're
going to
also do is we're going to cut right
through the breast of this
just so that we can put it on the um
sheet pan
and it will lay flat there we go okay we
blotted it
and there we go how do you like that you
see that we're gonna
we're gonna press down on it and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna make that
sticky mango chutney that we talked
about that's what i want to see
yeah it starts with red onion pro tip
put it in a food processor to mince it
because you want it nice and tiny so
that when you saute it nice and brown
it becomes like a paste and what you're
going to do is
right yeah that's a big protein yeah
yeah and you're going to add a quarter
of a teaspoon of cayenne
remember i go when it comes to cayenne
one and a half teaspoons
of good curry two tablespoons of
the zest of an orange and always make
sure that you
zest that orange before you juice it and
then we're going to take
two tablespoons of orange juice right
here
oh wow flavors two yeah and the best of
all
is this ginger which i have minced make
sure that you
peel it before you do it and in goes
the ginger and i think that's it we're
going to mix this
up and then we're going to add to it the
chutney this is the earl
earl grey i think it is earl grey
chutney and we're going to put this
in chutney is an indian east indian
flavor
and you can use any mango chutney right
doesn't matter what you really
have a preference no no i really don't
so let me just throw this in here
sorry about that now the key to this is
we're going to put this in between the
skin
now watch this this is such a great
thing is we're going to take this
chutney
and we are going to lift up the skin i'm
facing this towards you
and we're just going to put this in
between the skin
and the and the meat same over on this
side
there will be no shortage of flavor in
this dish
no right and wait till you see just how
beautiful so
you take this and you can see it's like
a paste because of the onion and the
garlic
red onion and garlic that we sauteed and
browned again anybody i wanted to let
the viewers know the recipe is on your
screen if you want to take a picture or
you know write it down yes and they can
also go to nannybubby.com to get it or
on my facebook or instagram
but look at all look at all of this
color isn't that gorgeous one more i
think
all right and now what we're going to do
is we're going to take these beautiful
vegetables
we're going to just toss them let me get
rid of these
gloves which have raw chicken on them
we're just going to toss this with some
olive oil you know cook's
best tools are these hands and we're
going to toss these
a little bit of salt and pepper was
already in here i love that keeping it
somewhere
veggies i like that yes yes and just
look
how beautiful this is do you see that
that is
gorgeous perfect for even if you're so
if you're hosting that's a great dish
too because it's so pretty
it's so colorful before you cook it but
let me show you what it looks like
after you cooked it as we open up the
chapman oven
and just take a look at this look at how
beautiful this is wow
look at that and that is a fully cooked
i'm not one
for carving a chicken but i want to tell
you when you cut out that bath
and you carve this chicken it just it's
fantastic a little bit of parsley
over the top just to add some green on
top of that orange
and boom and you've got yourself a
fabulous batch cut
chicken look at that parsley i don't
know i love it thank you so much to
anybody that looks amazing
you never cease to make this you too
have a great weekend
bye check out nanny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online as she
said nannybubby.com we want to also
thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this